you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 News Now
while we're seeing a lot more Sunshine
now as we look outside across the valley
really pretty out there and it feels
good too the winds really haven't hit
the valley yet but we've got some
locations starting to feel those breezes
up in the spring mountains out up at
mountain spring Summit between Pahrump
and Las Vegas and out in Boulder City
temperatures mostly warming into the 50s
now at the noon hour and we will reach
for some 60s today this is going to be
the warmest day of the week because once
that cold front moves through tonight
that's going to open the door for some
chillier air 58 Indian Springs 58 in
Pahrump 54 in Mesquite prompt you're
starting to feel some of those Southwest
breezes 60 in Laughlin now Reno has had
northwesterly winds since early this
morning being up there behind the cold
front already getting a taste of that
cooler air but 50 degrees that's not bad
for Reno really 63 is what we're looking
for 61 is normal sunset at 4 27 and by
Sunset to that cold front is going to be
very close to us this system is bringing
snow into the Northwest in the
Intermountain West already seeing some
snow in Northeastern Nevada right now
and then this system is going to drop
into the Southern Plains and mix with
the warm moist Gulf Air across the
Southern Plains and this is going to be
the Clash zone for possible severe
weather later tomorrow into Wednesday
could see some tornadoes across Texas
Oklahoma Arkansas and the Mid-South
chilly across the Great Lakes in the
Upper Midwest back here at home we're
going to cool down too there's the cold
front our clouds are thinning out the
winds are going to really be picking up
through the afternoon freeze watch for
the Central Valley of California and
these areas of blue if you have friends
and family leaving going back home from
the Thanksgiving holiday just let them
know it's going to be fairly windy
across interstates 15 and 40 into
Southern California for the rest of the
day and into tonight wind advisories in
place now until 10 p.m we have no wind
advisories but we will be fairly Breezy
through the afternoon Southwest winds up
to 25 miles an hour and again and the
warmest day of the week after that cold
front tonight we're looking at highs
only in the mid 50s Tuesday Wednesday
mornings in the 30s so hopefully those
heaters are working fine by the end of
the week some good news for us another
couple of systems dropping in to bring
us chances for rain late Friday and
better chances all day Saturday the
weekend may not be the best timing but
chances to linger into Sunday and we
sure do need the rain and the Mountain
snow Heather so we won't turn it away we
won't I'm just going to buy myself a
heated blanket here on Cyber Monday